what would you tell young women as their  role model I really look up to you  smiley face that's cute I would say  don't sleep around it just hurts that's  coming from somebody who you know had  experiences in University that hurt just  because everyone else is doing it  doesn't mean you have to do it doesn't  make you better it doesn't make men want  you more if anything it works in in the  opposite way and work on yourself watch  educational podcasts read books learn  how to do something and get your diet in  order get your sleep schedule on track  exercise there you go do all those  things and then you'll find somebody  because you'll be sane and also don't  take birth control it makes you crazy